[Music]
I'm fascinated by airplanes aviation is
an engineering miracle a form of divine
engineering you know Alan they both own
beautifully talked about the
awe-inspiring rapture one feels when one
bears witness to the power of a jet
engine to the power of a flying machine
and I remember the first time I saw the
a380 has hit me home but Alain de Botton
says nothing prepares you for the sense
of agility and self possession of a jet
airplane no structure of comparable size
a building or a Cathedral can compare to
that feeling of freedom of exhilaration
that that machine promises you know he
talks about walking through a corridor
that will lead you on to a craft that
will take you somewhere where no one
knows your name it becomes a kind of
ontological journey it becomes a journey
of self-realization of soaring above
one's limits you know the jet airplane
literalizes the human goal of
transcending our limitations it's always
a symbolic journey airlines don't
realize this people talk about how the
enchantment of flying the magic of fly
has faded and people are so bored
because they're closing their windows
they're afraid to look out they're
afraid to bear witness to what is
possible look at the appeal of those
screens in the airports with the promise
of destinations of spaces of happiness
places where the answers might lie you
know Alan the both on beautifully talks
about it
think of the the imaginative allure of
Paris of Amsterdam of the Czech Republic
of Cape Town oh my god these places sing
they sing to us they beckon
is the power of these transcendent
machines and we need to just open our
eyes a little bit you know
is a daily reminder every day of what's
possible this is who we are these are
our technological skins our scaffoldings
we have wings people we may be flawed
stumbling primates but when we work
together we are primates that can fly
hey guys we want to take a look at shots
of all behind the scenes how it all
comes to life we'll then check out this
episode I shot on seeker stories which
explores my daily rituals in how we make
shots of awe